buzu up rev wallow delusion a six
Hollywood grand in your Jacques
dormez-vous jacuzzi I'm saying other web
permits we will sock clamp Anwar dynamo
Zoot alors kudasai zero on de cine
unison quoi pas de deux
snowpiercer isn't there this is hard for
me but I'm just going to say it I don't
need any more Marvel or DC comic book
movies in the last decade alone if there
have been 40 of them it's too much
I need a Steve Ditko detox a Frank
Miller moratorium and a Jack Kirby
cleanse wait wait donate it in the Neal
scratch sound effect yeah I don't want
these comic book movies but I still want
comic book movies the solution the
French I know I recently dissed French
film makers for not putting parkour in
everything but French sequential artists
have my utmost respect on DNA are often
very adult and not just in the bare
breasted ultraviolence manner of handy
metal they can be dark to tale complex
and socially aware take snowpiercer
recently published in English for the
first time this series by jacques lob is
about the last surviving humans on a
non-stop train that endlessly circles of
frozen Desolator the train is a thousand
one cars long and poor were stuck in the
back stage a revolt against the rich
elite up in the first class now major
Hollywood studios
touch this bleep post-apocalyptic story
with a ten-foot baton
luckily South Korean director bong
joon-ho filmed an adaptation mostly in
English starring Chris Evans it's
terrific it's one of the best sci-fi
films you'll see this year now compare
snowpiercer to that other Chris Evans
coming there was just in theaters it was
one of the better MCU movies iMHO but
OTO H it's just a few political
complexities grafted onto a jingoistic
character who literally wears an
American flag Hollywood enough with the
Stan Lee cameos let's talk about
airtight garage the quest for the bird
of time lone Sloane the demon of the
Eiffel Tower and okay fine Belgian
comics - Adventures of Tintin that was a
pretty good movie wait a minute I'm
being told that the Smurfs started out
as a Belgian comic soccer man I take it
back
I take it back I take it back who would
win it an ink pen duel to the death
john-boy Dias Giro or Frank Miller let
me know in the comments and subscribe to
the wire channel